last story of the day Twitter is
erupting right now Twitter is erupting
guys I couldn't believe this happened
Ben Shapiro and Candice Owens are
literally going at it on Twitter on
Twitter as you guys know I have been
following Ben Shapiro and Candace Owens
so Candace Owens has been outspoken that
she does not believe in genocide now
when it comes to the Middle East or the
Israel situation I'm not an expert that
is not my my field but Candice had a
tweet saying that she believed that it
was wrong what Israel when Israel bombed
Palestine Ben Shapiro comes out and says
her behavior is Despicable at a private
event there was a clip of Ben saying
that he thought Candace 's Behavior was
Despicable I don't know if he thought he
was being recorded maybe he didn't but
this clip starts circulating on YouTube
now Candace Owen weighs in on this clip
on Tucker Carlson let's go so I can't
respond to it on a level of intellect
because there there's nothing that he
has expressed in that at least in that
short clip that he fundamentally
disagrees with in terms of what I said
but I will say that I'm not going to
respond with the same Ed hinant attacks
I don't think it helps further
discussion and it if that was me that
was caught on a video saying that about
colleagues that I work with I would be
embarrassed I would so I think that the
video speaks more to Ben's character
than it speaks to mine has he texted you
to apologize or explain or anything no
what tends to happen is of course we we
all have elements of selfishness within
us and so when it particularly pertains
to an issue that impacts you cace
is obviously upset as anyone would be
that Ben Shapiro is coming after her you
know she does this thing and I and I
have to be honest guys women do use
religion as a way to like kind of be
passive aggressive we to like we we do
that we do that and she does a tweet
which is clearly about her previous
tweet condemning genocide blessed are
the peacemakers for they shall be called
the children of God blessed are they who
are persecuted for righteousness' sake
for theirs is the Kingdom of Heaven
blessed are you where men shall revile
you and persecute you and say all manner
of evil against you falsely for my
name's sake no one can serve two masters
either you will hate the one and love
the other or you will be devoted to one
and despise the other you cannot serve
both God and money so Ben Shapiro comes
in and says Candice if you feel that
taking money from the daily wire somehow
comes between you and God by all means
it I'm like
what this public Feud this public Feud I
never thought I would be in a world
where political
commentators are publicly like quitting
and getting F I mean no one's quit yet
but I mean I can't imagine this goes in
a different direction Candace says you
have been acting unprofessional and
emotionally unhinged for weeks now we
all have to sit back and allow it and
have to exercise exceeding understanding
for your raw emotion you are utterly out
of line for suggesting that I cannot
quote Biblical scripture the Bible is
not about you yeah okay I gotta be
honest though
Candice
Candice I think I I think it could be
inferred that she was implying but at
the same time I I think I would have
just ignored it if I was Ben I I don't
think it was worth responding to um I am
genuinely confused while asking
questions and quoting Bible verses about
peace warrants to call a resign from the
daily why there should be more room in
the conservative movement for
disagreement we can do better than this
yeah and I don't know what it is about
this issue this issue like I've seen it
like tear apart professional
relationships in front of our eyes when
it's like why can't we just talk freely
and explore both sides but you can't
even do that without getting demonetized
on YouTube guys I don't know I'm not
saying this is the reason but I am
saying it's interesting timing um okay
but let me know whose side you are on
Ben Shapiro or Candace Owens I am a fan
of both both of them I think they're
both awesome um so it's unfortunate to
see them fighting like this but very
entertaining and I saw a story where a
man lost
weight after a friend texted him fat F
every day for six
weeks so this guy just called him fat
for six weeks straight and this guy lost
all of his weight can you imagine if
that was a woman we would just go to our
room and cry or something Mike says men
and women are not the same that's a good
friend and I think this is also why
women will always be more lonely than
men by ourselves men have real genuine
true friendships that last a lifetime
women generally don't we go through
friends very quickly women generally
turn on each other women have a much
harder time having lifelong
relationships and it shows chosen
marriage I mean we quit everything you
think we're going to stick we we we
can't even stick out our husbands you
think we're going to stick out
friendships we'll have kids with the guy
and not stick that out um but again I
think it results in men having deeper
and more meaningful friendships than
women generally do Patriot dad says this
is how men communicate and should this
is a good friend who showed him he cared
by letting him know he was unhealthy and
needed to fix it you can't do this with
a woman they will get their feelings
hurt and hate you for it men need to be
told the truth and women do too and we
need to start learning how to take it
because this Society goes crazy when you
have to constantly lie to us flame says
see dudes be straight up with their
friends and results happen girls lie to
their friends straight up two more
stories today so Megan rapo is a female
soccer player and i' I've spoken out
against Megan because I really think
she's just a crybaby that wants better
pay in sports I'm a female athlete I
play basketball volleyball I did it for
16 years okay um I understand why we
make less and I'm very grateful for men
for subsidizing women's leagues and
allowing me to play as long as I I did I
think I learned to work hard I think it
made me learn how to accomplish goals I
think it kept me out of a lot of TR
trouble I am very grateful for athletics
in my life now there's pros and cons to
every decision but I'll say one thing it
had a lot of Pros it helped me get along
with people and made me more social and
I will never complain about pay even
though I could I had the opportunity to
go play professionally and I decided not
to because I didn't want to pursue the
pay even though I love playing life is
about choices and trade-offs some people
want to be an artist and make 0 for a
lifetime you don't blame the customer
you blame the product so there is a
video of Megan disrespecting God so not
only does she want to mislead young
women that were oppressed somehow not
only does she want these special
treatment and privileges not only does
she complain about a league that is
subsidized by the men she also
disrespects God take a look yeah I
thought about it a little bit I mean you
know I'm not a religious person or
anything and if there was was a god like
this is proof that there isn't up
um so yeah it just it's just up
guys like it's six minutes
in so bad yes you're good no way so she
had a career-ending injury and she's in
her 30s I want to say like mid-30s um
how much longer did you expect to play
chica you know I would be grateful that
you weren't injured so far and you got
to take your career to such a high level
you know I've never been that seriously
injured I've had like small problems
here and there and I'm really grateful
that my career the majority was
relatively injuryf free she wants to
disrespect God and say this is proof
that he doesn't exist because I I was
injured maybe you just stepped on your
foot wrong chica um and I don't
understand why non-religious people
can't just be respectful of religious
people you don't have to believe what
they believe but why do you have to go
out of your way to disrespect them it's
the same thing I saw a nun Halloween
costume it was like why just Le
let the religious people be religious so
the comment section was cooking her she
says she represents everything wrong
with our society now and her fall from
pride is proof that God does exist yes
yeah that woman is so prideful